je pense que l'équipe de France montre
que non seulement elle s'adapte mais
domine en fait lorsqu'elle rencontre un
adversaire qui est talentueux dit c'est
le cas des deux derniers matchs et finit
par gagner c'est une véritable équipe de
gagnants bien manager comme vous l'avez
indiqué tout à l'heure il cajole il
punit l'équilibre sans des champs nous
n'en serions pas là c'est ma conviction
la force la gagne la victoire sont en
lui et certains
osent parler de chance pardonnez-leur
mon Dieu ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils
font
il y en aura une troisième dimanche soir
elle est là la troisième pour vous on
vous la donne
si notre top 5 des réflexions les plus
connues qu'on a entendu ce weekend sur
cnews numéro 5 la dame qui fait tout le
temps la gueule à la télé moi en
l'occurrence j'étais sur le périphérique
au moment de la victoire du Maroc vous
avez vraiment l'impression de vivre à
Casablanca donc c'est ah non alors je
vous arrête tout de suite ça roule
beaucoup mieux à Casablanca
[Applaudissements]
tous les soirs cnews soit la cible la
cible de quotidien je pense que ce n'est
pas convenable alors ce n'est pas
monsieur Barthez d'ailleurs qu'elle
seule responsable monsieur Barthez il
est à l'oreillette il ne dit jamais rien
qui ne soit écrit par quelqu'un d'autre
c'est son producteur Laurent bon qui
écrit tout et qui fait tout il a mis
tout le monde d'accord et lui homme du
match Antoine Griezmann a impressionné
les internautes pour qui il est même le
meilleur joueur de ce Mondial avis
partagé par un Matt Pokora catégorique
hier Griezmann s'est occupé de tout à
tel point que certains n'ont vu que lui
sur le terrain numéro 2 les drapeaux
maghrébins le drapeau arabout musulman
sont restés très visibles dans une sorte
d'appropriation
vous avez un journaliste qui dit ta
gueule ta gueule et il traite également
de réflexion cônes et il met en danger
les gens qui font cette chaîne je le dis
monsieur belle-mère président de TF1
Martin Bouygues est-ce que vous tolérez
ça on est très fiers immensément fier et
je pense que nos compatriotes ont besoin
de de joie simple et pure le sport en
procure le foot tout particulièrement
moi j'étais favorable je le demeure à un
boycott diplomatique et je pense que la
place du président de la République
d'autant plus quand on découvre qu'il y
a des affaires de corruption et que le
Qatar c'est permis d'acheter le silence
au Parlement européen en plus d'avoir
acheté la Coupe du Monde directement au
lieu où se trouve maintenant Emmanuel
Macron du temps de Nicolas Sarkozy à
l'Élysée en tant que président de la
République moi j'aurais préféré
afficher un boycott diplomatique auprès
de cette Coupe du Monde équipe de France
n'a pas besoin d'Emmanuel Macron pour
gagner par contre les droits humains
alors que 6500 ouvriers sont morts sur
les chantiers du Qatar et bien ont
besoin de la voix de la France pour
porter vous lui dites maintenant il ne
faut pas y aller dimanche moi je jeter
pour que Emmanuel Macron et Nicolas
Sarkozy soit privé de télé ce qui me
[Musique]
de troubler le président de la
République peut-être était-il au courant
d'ailleurs je sais pas